now most people think that new
technology or advanced technology can
never start in Africa instead they think
that the best way to help the continent
advance is by providing aid or services
that the the continent can't provide for
itself so while we see advanced
technology like robotics and artificial
intelligence growing exponentially in
the developed world those same people
are worried that a technologically
backward Africa is falling behind that
attitude couldn't be more wrong I'm a
robotics entrepreneur who spent a lot of
time here in Africa and in 2014 we
created a zipline which is a company
that uses electric autonomous aircraft
to deliver medicine to hospitals and
health centers on demand and last year
we launched the world's first automated
delivery system operating at national
scale and guess what we did not do that
in the US we didn't do it in Japan and
we didn't do it in Europe it was
actually president Paul Kagame and the
Rwandan Ministry of Health that made a
big bet on the potential of this
technology and signed a commercial
contract to deliver a majority of the
country's blood on demand
yeah they deserve the applause so why is
blood important Rwanda collects between
sixty and eighty thousand units of blood
a year so this is a product that when
you need it you really really need it
but blood is also challenging because it
has a very short shelf life there are
lots of different storage requirements
and it's really hard to predict the
demand for all of these different blood
groups before a patient actually needs
something but the cool thing is that
using this technology Rwanda has been
able to keep more blood centralized and
then provide it when a patient needs
something to any hospital or health
center in an average of just 20 or 30
minutes so do you guys want to see how
it works
alright nobody believes me so better -
better - oh this is our distribution
center which is about 20 kilometres
outside of Kigali this actually used to
be a cornfield
nine months ago and with the Rwandan
government we leveled it and built this
Center in a couple weeks so when a
patient's having an emergency a doctor
or a nurse at that hospital can send us
a whatsapp telling us what they need and
then our team will immediately spring
into action we pull the blood from our
stock which is delivered by the National
Center for blood transfusion we scan the
blood into our system so the Ministry of
Health knows where the blood is going
and then will basically pack it into a
zip which is what we call these little
autonomous airplanes that run on
batteries and then once that zip is
ready to go we accelerate it from zero
to 100 kilometers an hour in about half
of a second and from the moment it
leaves the end of the launch where it's
completely autonomous this is our air
traffic controller calling it in to
Kigali International Airport and when
the zip arrives at the hospital it
descends to about 30 feet and drops the
package we use a really simple paper
parachute simple things are best it
allows the package to come to the ground
gently and reliably in the same place
every time and so it's it's just like
ride-sharing the doctors get a text
message one minute before we arrive
saying walk outside and receive your
delivery and then
and then the and then the doctors have
what they need to save a patient's life
so this is actually watching a delivery
happen from our distribution center and
this vehicle is about 50 kilometers away
we're able to watch the vehicle as it
makes a delivery at a hospital in real
time and you may have noticed there are
pings that are coming off of that
vehicle on the screen those pings are
actually data packets that we're getting
over the cellphone networks so these
planes have SIM cards just like your
cell phone does and they're
communicating over the cell network to
tell us where they are and how they're
doing at all times so believe it or not
we actually buy family plans for this
fleet of vehicles because that's how we
get the best rates it's actually not a
joke so today we're delivering about 20%
of the National blood supply of Rwanda
outside of Kigali we serve about 12
hospitals and we're adding hospitals to
that network at an accelerating rate and
all of those hospitals only receive
blood in this way and and most of those
hospitals actually place multiple orders
every day so the reason in in all of
healthcare logistics you're always
trading off waste against access so if
you if you want to solve waste you keep
everything centralized and and as a
result when patients are having
emergencies sometimes they don't have
the medical product that they need if
you want to solve access you stock a lot
of medicine at the last mile at
hospitals or health centers and then
patients have the medicine they need but
you end up throwing a lot of medicine
out which is very very expensive what's
so amazing is that the Rwandan
government has been able to break this
cycle permanently they because doctors
can get what they need instantly they
actually stock less blood at the
hospitals
so although use of blood products has
increased substantially at all the
hospitals we serve in the last nine
months zero units of blood have expired
at any of these hospitals
that's an amazing result that's actually
not been achieved by any other
healthcare system on the planet and it
happened here but obviously when we're
talking about delivering medical
products instantly the most important
thing is patients and so let me let me
give you an example a couple months ago
a 24-year old mother came into one of
the hospitals that we serve and she gave
birth via c-section but that led to
complications and she started to bleed
luckily the doctors had some blood of
her blood type on hand that had been
delivered via zip lines routine service
and so they transfused her with a couple
units of blood but she bled out of those
units in about ten minutes in this case
that mother's life is in grave danger in
any hospital in the world but luckily
her doctors who are taking care of her
immediately called our distribution
center they placed an emergency order
and our team actually did emergency
delivery after emergency delivery after
emergency delivery they ended up sending
seven units of red blood cells four
units of plasma and two units of
platelets that's more blood than you
have in your entire body all of it was
transfused into her the doctors were
able to stabilize her and she is healthy
today
since we launched we've done about 400
emergency deliveries like that and
there's a story like that one behind
most of those emergencies here are just
a couple of the moms who have received
transfusions in this way in the last
couple months and you know we're always
reminded when we can help a doctor save
a mom's life it's not just her life that
you're saving that's also a baby boy or
a baby girl who has a mother while
they're growing up but I want to be
clear you know postpartum hemorrhaging
it's not a Rwanda problem it's not a
developing world problem this is a
global problem maternal health is a
challenge everywhere the main difference
is that Rwanda was the first country to
use radical technology to do something
about it
and that's the reason that this attitude
of you know Africa being disrupted or
advanced technology not working here or
needing Aid is so totally wrong
Africa can be the disrupter like these
the small agile developing economies can
out innovate large rich ones and they
can totally leapfrog over the absence of
legacy infrastructure to go straight to
newer and better systems so in 2000 if
you had said that high-quality cellular
networks were about to roll out across
all of Africa people would have told you
you were crazy and yet I mean no one
anticipated how fast those those
networks were going to connect and
empower people and today 44 percent of
the GDP of Kenya flows through and pacer
their mobile payment platform and not
only that but our autonomous fleet of
vehicles relies on that cellular network
and over the next few years as we start
serving private health care facilities
we'll also use that mobile payment
platform to collect fees for deliveries
so innovation leads to more innovation
leads to more innovation and meanwhile
most people who live in developed
economies think that drone delivery is
technologically impossible let alone
happening at national scale in East
Africa and I do mean East Africa not
just Rwanda on Thursday just a couple
days ago the Tanzanian Ministry of
Health
announced that they are going to use
this same technology to provide instant
delivery of a wide range of medical
products to 10 million of the hardest
reach people in the country it's
actually going to be the largest
autonomous system anywhere in the world
to give you a sense for what this looks
like this is one of the first
distribution centers you can see a 75
kilometers service radius around the
distribution center and that actually
allows us to serve hundreds of health
facilities and hospitals all of which
are rural from that single distribution
center but to serve you know over 20% of
the population of Tanzania we're going
to need multiple distribution centers
will actually need four and from these
distribution centers we'll be doing we
expect to be doing several hundred
life-saving deliveries every day and
this system will ultimately serve over a
thousand health facilities and hospitals
in the country so yeah East Africa is
moving really fast and one thing that
people I think often miss is that these
kinds of leaps generate compounding
gains I mean for example Rwanda by
investing in this infrastructure for
healthcare now has an aerial logistics
network that they can use to catalyze
other parts of their of their economy
like agriculture or e-commerce even more
importantly a hundred percent of the
teams that we hire at these distribution
centers are local so here's our Rwandan
team which is a group of extraordinary
engineers and operators they run the
world's only automated delivery system
operating at national scale they have
been able to master something that the
largest technology companies in the
world have not yet been able to figure
out so they are total heroes
they're total heroes our team's mission
is to deliver basic access to medicine
to all 7 billion people on the planet no
matter how hard it is to reach them but
we often tell people about that mission
and they say oh it's so generous of you
it's so philanthropic no philanthropy
has nothing to do with it
because of the commercial contract that
we signed with ministries of health
these networks are a hundred percent
sustainable and scalable and the reason
we feel so strongly about correcting
that misperception is that
entrepreneurship is the only force in
human history that has lifted millions
of people out of poverty no amount of
foreign aid is going to sustainably
employ 250 million African youth so you
know and and the jobs that these kids
may have gotten 10 years ago are largely
being automated or are being changed
dramatically by technology so they are
looking for new skill sets new
competitive advantages they're looking
for startups so why aren't there more
startups that are tackling these global
problems that are faced by billions of
people in developing economies the
reason is that investors and
entrepreneurs are totally blind to the
opportunity we think these problems are
the domain of NGOs or governments not
private companies that's what we have to
change so you may have noticed I left
something out of the video that I showed
you I didn't show you how the planes
land when they get back to the
distribution center so I mean it might
be obvious to you none of our planes
have landing gear we also don't have
runways where we operate so we have to
be able to decelerate the plane from
about a 100 kilometers an hour to zero
and half of a second and the way that we
do that is we actually use a wire that
tracks the plane as it comes in with
centimeter level accuracy we snag the
plane out of this guy and then we gently
plop it onto an actively inflated
cushion is this basically a combination
of an aircraft carrier and a bouncy
castle
so let me show you
[Music]
and it might be obvious to why I wanted
to end with this video I wanted to show
you the kids and the teenagers who line
up on the fence every day and they cheer
every launch and every landing sometimes
I actually show up at the distribution
center early because I'm jet lag so I'll
show up an hour before we begin
operation and there will be kids on the
fence getting good seats and you go up
and you ask them what do you think about
the planes and they'll say oh it's a sky
ambulance so they get it I mean they get
it more than most adults so I was asking
earlier who is going to be creating the
disruptive technologies the disruptive
technology companies of Africa over the
next decade ultimately it's going to be
up to these kids they are the engineers
of Rwanda and Africa they are the
engineers of our shared future but the
only way they can build that future is
if we realize that world-changing
companies can scale in Africa and the
disruptive technology can start here
first Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]